mais pas une dent soit bien menée à
24,60 bonsoir cette entrevue télévisée
madame le pen depuis votre arrivée vous
avez soulevé certaines susciter
certaines controverses jeu nous faire
entendre ce qui s'est passé sur nos
ondes arrête canada hier soir lors du
gala du cinéma écoutez bien aujourd'hui
j'étais comme très choqué il y a
quelqu'un qui visitent le québec qui
vient de la vieille france qui se
promènent à droite et à droite à dire
des choses qui ne correspondent pas à
une certaine réalité
notamment il critique les gouvernements
du canada et du québec pour avoir ouvert
les portes aux réfugiés syriens
et le pire c'est que elle dit qu' elles
critiquent ce gouvernement pour défendre
la culture québécoise
je ne pouvais pas ne pas vous parler de
ça aujourd'hui parce que la culture
québécoise
elle n'a pas besoin de ce type de
défense nous pourrons le faire lire
et le pen ce monsieur est cinéaste au
grand cinéaste d'origine chilienne il
était dans l'entourage de salvador
allende au début des années soixante dix
avant que le canada devienne son pays
d'accueil au fond il vous dit de vous
mêler de vos affaires que vous êtes venu
donner des leçons aux canadiens puis
vous faites des rebonds n'a pas besoin
de vous d'abord d'abord ce monsieur n'a
probablement pas écouter ce que j'ai dit
mais ça c'est assez traditionnel c'est
un c'est un fait commun que les acteurs
les cinéastes les chanteurs se mêlent de
politique mais ce que ce monsieur oui
bien sûr ils ont le droit de le faire
mais ce que ce monsieur oublie c'est que
il ya un concept que je crois nous
sommes tous attachés s'appelle la
démocratie et la démocratie ça consiste
aussi à entendre ceux qui sont en
désaccord avec vous figurez vous c'est
merveilleux comme concept pour peu qu'on
le respecte
- voyez vous ça ne me dérange absolument
pas que tout un chacun puisse avoir des
positions divergentes des miennes mais
je trouve un peu étonnant que on
interdise d'aborder un certain nombre de
sujets ou que d'interrogations de ces
sujets entraîne une forme plus
d'hystérie en retour jan manten pourquoi
parce que je pense que dans une
démocratie mature
eh bien chacun peut débattre être
d'accord ou être en désaccord 900 mm sur
nous sommes en démocratie maintien vous
qui dit par exemple que avoir 25 mille
réfugiés syriens c'est une folie les
atlas fois les unités politique oui mais
comme c'est ma conviction politique
alors vous avez pu dire tout ce que vous
avez oublié depuis que vous êtes là et
les gens vous répondrais oui monsieur
liechti le problème ce qui me pose un
problème c'est que j'ai l'impression que
je viens je dis je suis contre
l'immigration on a le droit de dire ça
ou on n'a pas droit jeu si on n'a pas le
droit il faut le dire tout de suite il
faut dire si vous dites que vous êtes
contre l'immigration on va vous insultez
vous traitez de raciste et xénophobe de
replier sur vous-même de fasciste je ne
sais quoi
il faut le dire est ce qu'on a le droit
de dire moi je suis contre le
communautarisme je pense est un mauvais
dell l'action n'a le droit de le dire ou
est-ce qu'on se fait insulter en
retournait c'est ça la vraie question
est ce qu'on a le droit d'évoquer ses
idées ou est ce qu'on a le droit
d'évoquer que les idées qui sont
autorisés par une certaine oligarchie
par une certaine caste par la
bien-pensance
parce que si c'est ça et bien croyez moi
ceux qui essayent de m'empêcher de jaser
vont en être pour leurs frais vous vous
nourrissez peut-être de cette
victimisation vous évoquez la démocratie
vous arriver s'il vous avez l'insultent
au bout des lèvres à chaque moment qui
jeu qui est jean sultan ben adda et je
sais moi j'ai été libéré le l'église
insulté le leadership et je vous aime
entendre un extrait de vaud et les
mentionner que notre classe politique
était un monde de bisounours qui avait
deux listes vous n'êtes tout juste de me
dire la question vous avez déclenché
l'hystérie que vous
oui alors madame oui jeudi qu' un
certain nombre de gouvernements sont
naïfs face aux problématiques de
l'immigration c'est ce que j'appelle le
monde de bisounours
j'ai connu des injures plus grave quand
même que celle là bon mais quand on
était à grenay injure non divisée nord
c'est le concept qui consiste à
considérer que tout va bien que tout est
merveilleux qu'il y aura jamais aucun
problème alors que moi je dis qu'il y a
des problèmes que c'est vous mêmes
peuvent s'aggraver
oui mais que les mêmes causes en train
de les mêmes effets ça sera ça les vaut
la sagesse populaire l'attelage qu'en
savez vous le bain parce que je vois
bien ce qui s'est passé en france
notamment au québec
je vois bien ce que je vois bien la
dérive du communautarisme qui créent
comme partout d'ailleurs parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'exception comme partout des
revendication politico-religieuse de
plus en plus importantes auxquelles une
partie des québécois avec lesquelles une
partie des québécois sont en désaccord
voilà j'expose mes idées politiques
madame je suis ému et je suis à la tête
alors du premier parti de france
alors oui mais vous n'êtes pas encore
présidente alors comment m me lise et
sam interdit de parler maintenant je
m'attends à ce que si les cinq ils
peuvent parler sont les présidents
alors effectivement c'est ennuyeux alors
comme vous émettrez démocratie le débat
permettez moi de poser des questions
mais j'en suis a pris depuis tout à
l'heure
s'ils ne sont pas tellement des
questions c'est plus un réquisitoire
d'accord alors alors
avais je vous cite donc les 26 et
l'immigration c'est de la folie
notre classe politique et victimes de
terrorisme intellectuel
est ce que vous êtes venu en campagne
électorale présidentielle faire la leçon
aux canadiens aux québécois qui ont des
gouvernements démocratiquement élus
je ne fais la leçon à personne qu'est ce
que vous faites je note que je suis
arrivé je n'ai pas demandé à avoir des
responsables politiques
voilà je ne sens n'était pas ni le but
de mon voyage ni en l'occurrence mon
objectif l'intégralité de la classe
politique a pris la parole pour dire
jamais nous ne rencontrons pas nous ne
voulons pas lui parler et c'est des gens
ont cherché à me voir des rendez-vous
ont été fixés à leur demande et ils ont
annulé ses rendez vous si ça n'est pas
ça du terrorisme intellectuel
s'ils n'ont pas eu peur de quelque chose
comment se fait-il que des gens
réclament de me voir et que à partir du
moment où il ya de l'agitation
médiatique et bien ils renoncent à me
voir parce qu'ils ont peur est ce que
c'est ça c'est la vie c'est la question
je pense je suis confronté aux
événements moi je les analyse madame
beau d'ailleurs de si simple que cela je
ne donne la leçon absolument alors
qu'est-ce qui vous comprendre de votre
discours de ce que vous arrivez ici vous
êtes que c'est une erreur de
d'accueillir 25 mille réfugiés à
l'enquêté ce gouvernement a été élu
démocratiquement en faisant cette
promesse
le canada est en tain et le québec sont
des terres d'accueil depuis des
décennies et qui sont les terrils j'ai
j'ai du mal à croire que vous ne sachiez
pas ce que c'est la démocratie la
démocratie ça ne consiste pas se taire
devant ceux qui ont été élus parce que
la démocratie ne fonctionne madame que
s'il ya des gens élus et des gens qui
sont dans l'opposition éventuellement
nous avons des sujets sur lequel avec
les socialistes de tous les pays nous
avons des désaccords avec mes socialiste
français nous avons des désaccords forts
avec les socialistes au sein du
parlement européen de l'ensemble des
pays de l'union européenne eh bien nous
avons des désaccords
ai-je le droit de les exprimer donc je
les exprime jeudi je pense que la
politique d'immigration choix est fait
mises en oeuvre par monsieur trudeau est
une folie ai je le droit de le dire
moi aussi je n'ai pas le droit mais il
faut m'interdire l'entrée du pays qui
s'est pas dit si c'était un autre voyage
que manifestement les jeans et un
certain nombre de dirigeants de
ministres vient d'annuler l'intégralité
des rendez vous qu'ils avaient avec la
délégation de la commission commerce
international du parlement européen
faisons preuve
permettez moi au moins quand même de 10
courtoisie à l'égard d'élus qui viennent
de l'ensemble des pays d'europe pour
discuter avec des responsables
politiques de l'accord entre les haies
entre le canada et l'union européenne et
de toute une série d'autres sujets il
n'y a pas un problème n'ont pas cessé
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas un souci de
trouver que c'est normal vous trouvez
que c'est un un comportement normal moi
je ne trouve pas ce qui lui donnait aux
servier vous infréquentables parce que
vous arrivez et des gens voient dans vos
discours que vous exprimiez tout à fait
librement des insultes des injures et
des leçons ne remontera dame
donnez moi une seule insulte vous êtes
journaliste madame oui la militante
journaliste mais non leurs causes et les
portions par conséquent vous êtes obligé
deux analyse factuelle des choses
montrez-moi une insulte alors je vais
disons tous tort ces gens là non montre
moi madame vous avez dit insuffler agir
montrez-moi une insulte miens japon pas
vos questions madame c'est moi qui pour
des questions
ababord madame le procureur alors si
c'est vous qui posez la question en
effet dans ces termes là je veux faire
un teint mais là je n'ai insulté
personne al très bien à la jeune et
injuriée perd 5 ans alors je dis ce que
je pense et je le dis avec franchise et
je crois que beaucoup de québécois
aiment la franchise si j'en crois
l'avalanche de messages madame que j'ai
reçu deux québécois sur mon compte
facebook et qui me dise madame le pen
nous sommes heureux de vous entendre
parler de cela car il y un satan de
sujet tabou au québec et nous sommes
heureux de voir que votre présence
suscite le débat sur des sujets dont
nous pensons qu'ils devraient être des
sujets abordés dans le cadre de la la
russie fait je me réjouis d'ailleurs
facebook est un outil plus démocratique
dans le fond que la parole de nos
efforts visant à faire entendre la
parole de nous
lui je faire entendre notre premier
ministre du québec monsieur guillard et
je vais vous aussi vous citer un texte
de monsieur péladeau du parti québécois
qui estime en tout cas que son parti ne
rien avoir avec vos valeurs votre
doctrine ça ne correspond pas alors j'ai
eu envie et julien entendu j'ai entendu
ce qu'il avait à dire je m'en étonne
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya au moins deux
sujets que je vois immédiatement qui
sont des sujets sur lequel on pourrait
au moins avoir un débat d'ailleurs avec
le parti québécois la souveraineté et la
défense de la francophonie
mais monsieur péladeau ne semble pas
absolument pas voir dans votre programme
des similitudes avec le mode je vous
donnais je voulais faire entendre ce
qu'il ya et puis surtout c'est celui qui
est allé en arabie saoudite ya pas très
longtemps et qui revenu en étant devenu
un ami du communautarisme alors qu'il en
était l'adversaire c'est celui-là non
d'accord j'en ai parlé très brièvement
écoutez madame le pen ne détient aucune
fonction au gouvernement français elle
est en visite sur tout ce que j'ai à
dire sur elle les jantes j'ai
certainement pas l'intention de démarrer
un débat avec marie avec madame le pen
et monsieur péladeau ont pu faire
entendre votre réponse aux étudiants qui
ont manifesté comme le faisaient les
gamins allez vous coucher vous trouvez
madame ces gens mais on gagne ce que
vous dites à l'intérieur on va les gens
prendre mais on va les entendre
vous chantez faut aller les gars allez
vous coucher maintenant madame moi je
comme un énorme problème c'est jeunes
militants d'extrême gauche se sont
introduits dans une conférence de presse
que j'ai organisé de force ils sont
venus m'insulter me traiter de fasciste
de nagy me dire que il m'emmerdait et il
aurait fallu quoi pour vous plaire que
je leur offre le déjeuner que je les
remercie peut-être d'être venir ainsi
perturber une conférence de presse
en effectuant des violences
c'est ça que j'aurais dit au fond la
parole nommé madame est-ce que c'est
cela que j'aurais dû faire
oui ou non c'est quand même une vision
un peu particulière mais moi je ne
perturbe la les réunions de personnes
moi je ne m du pas dans les conférences
de presse pour venir insulter les uns et
les autres vous et vous avez l'air
d'avoir beaucoup de complaisance pour
ces jeunes d'extrême gauche alors vous
avez aussi entrepris de refaire au front
national
une sorte
ce que les français ou dans plusieurs
commentateurs france ion apple a dit
dédiabolisation de votre parti prend des
distances par rapport à votre père jean
marie le pen
est-ce que son exclusion du parti a
quelque chose à voir avec votre désir de
refaire l'image du parti non madame je
m'excuse et moi mais je suis une
responsable politique
ce serait bien si on parlait de
politique parce que depuis le début de
cette émission j'ai l'impression
d'assister à un tribunal où vous auriez
la place on peut questionner votre style
va transformer se marier la place de la
procureure non non non non non depuis
depuis le début de cette émission vous
ne m'interrogez pas pour savoir ce que
je pense alors je vais vous menez vous
mener un véritable une véritable science
de tribunal
je n'entends pas me soumettre à votre
tribunal madame
alors donc soit vous m'interrogez sur
mes idées politiques et je vous
répondrai avec grand plaisir et avec le
sourire car c'est mon habitude à prendre
si c'est pour perdre si c'est pour
répondre si vous voulez à toute une
série un acte d'accusation
je trouve d'ailleurs profondément
injuste eh bien je ne me soumettrai pas
mais alors c'est pas du tout à l'écouté
je vais pas les déclarations publiques
beaucoup de sens que ce soit votre
propre nièce a dit que le front national
doit son succès à la dernière seconde 1
marion son succès au fait que jean marie
le pen a commencé à contester les flux
migratoires avant qu'il ne soit une
urgence d'obsession exemple et donc
votre discours sur l'immigration est ce
qu'il engendre
comme vous l'a dit depuis le début cet
entretien doit parler politique quand
même on a parlé d'immigration une
certaine intolérance
mais en quoi le fait d'être contre
l'immigration est une preuve
d'intolérance
est ce que c'est un repli sur soi je
vomis mais ce n'est ni du racisme ni un
repli sur soi ni de l'intolérance
l'immigration est un phénomène c'est un
phénomène mondial
c'est d'abord un phénomène économique
beaucoup de pays utilisent l'immigration
pour peser à la baisse sur les salaires
parce qu'ils vont chercher là de la main
d'oeuvre à bas coût
je trouve cela permettez-moi déplorable
parce que on se sert de gens que l'on
fait travailler à bas coûts est
évidemment que l'on met en concurrence
avec les compatriotes du pays
je suis opposé à cette utilisation bien
souvent par le grand patronat d'ailleurs
deux des masses d'immigration
deuxièmement l'immigration dans des pays
où il ya du chômage
ça consiste à faire venir des gens qui
n'ont vont pas trouver d'emploi
par définition puisque il y à du chômage
il n'y a pas d'emploi donc si on fait
venir des gens sans rien leur offrir eh
bien ces gens vont peser sur le système
de protection sociale c'est donc à mon
avis une aberration sur le plan
économique
et troisièmement je trouve ça très
injuste parce qu'en réalité on leur fait
croire que ils vont rejoindre l'eldorado
et bien souvent ils terminent sans
emploi dans une forme de difficultés et
contraint à rester au sein d'une
communauté et ça n'est pas ma vision de
l'homme
alors ça n'est pas la vision que j'ai ni
de l'homme ni de l'économie et donc je
suis opposé à cette politique
alors est-ce pour cela que dans votre
programme que j'ai devant moi sur
l'immigration sur l'application de la
priorité nationale
c'est qu'à compétences égales des
personnes qui ont la nationalité
française doivent avoir préséance sur
les immigrants que ils ont la même
priorité pour ce qui est du logement
social et qu'un étranger qui ne trouvent
pas de travail
un étranger en situation légale qui ne
trouvent pas de la gare de travail en
temps d'un an seront incités à retourner
dans leur pays au bout d'un an
d'inactivité
ça c'est comme il ya deux classes de
stress que les immigrants sont des
citoyens de seconde zone pour vous sont
des citoyens de seconde zone pour vous
mais madame pardon toutes les
constitutions au monde
admettre qu'entre ceux qui ont la
nationalité ceux qui n'ont pas la
nationalité
il ya évidemment des différences de fond
canada avec les chartes québécoise et
canadienne daily mail madame 6 très bien
ont tous égaux
non mais c'est parfait c'est très bien
je suis très heureuse pour vous je suis
pas sûr tous les québécois sont très
heureux
oui à compétences égales et à
compétences égales je pense que il est
tout à fait normal qu'un nationale
puisse avoir une priorité d'accès à
l'emploi
je trouve ça mais d'un bon sens absolu
d'un bon sens absolu pourquoi parce que
le français il a qu'un seul but donc
s'il peut pas travailler dans son pays
eh bien il est difficile pour lui de
l'obliger à s'expatrier pas dire alors
que l'étranger qui vient à 6 music et le
racisme y at il des scans à l'étranger
qui vient dans un pays et qui ne
trouvent pas d'emploi
eh bien il peut rentrer dans son pays
d'origine où est le racisme ne voit
absolument aucune trace de racisme dans
cette proposition dont je vous signale
que la suisse la met en oeuvre
le maroc met en oeuvre sans que personne
n'imagine une demi-seconde d'aller les
traiter de raciste vous savez pour
canada vous devez le connaître bien le
québec et le canada et on a des chartes
canadienne et la discrimination selon
l'origine et tout ça ce n'est pas une
discrimination selon l'origine c'est
encore une fois une priorité d'accès à
l'emploi et au logement social donné aux
nationaux à ceux qui ont la nationalité
quelle que soit leur couleur quelle que
soit leur origine quelle que soit leur
religion
on ne s'attache pas à ces considérations
on s'attache à l'appartenance à la
nation à la nationalité c'est l'ours
ligot de notre programme
par conséquent neutre soyez pas étonnés
de trouver cela dans ce programme c'est
tout à fait légitime et naturelle peut
être légitime naturel pour des personnes
de s'interroger sur le caractère
discriminatoire ou le discrète le
caractère raciste de cette politique
non c'est pas lisse et des maladies
questionner les dames quel racisme
expliquez moi parce que je n'arrive pas
à comprendre quel est le racisme dans
cette police pose la question
non mais je vous ai répondu mais vous
continuez à me parler de racisme qu'elle
racing y at-il dans cette politique
alors elle est le rascisme là je vois je
n'arrive même pas à comprendre et bien
alors la question de l'immigration est
un jeu booster votre nièce marion qui
c'est votre père en fait qui dit que
c'est grâce à votre père que ce discours
là dans le fond
un grand succès au front national et est
ce que vous croyez que c'est cette c'est
ce filon là au fond qui a le socle de
votre politique qui va vous permettre de
continuer d'avancer
non non dans les années soixante dix le
grand patronat français a fait appel à
l'immigration pour peser à la baisse sur
les salaires
ils cherchaient de la main d'oeuvre à
bas coût bon ils ont organisé donc
l'immigration et à l'issue de cette
immigration de travail
ils ont mis en oeuvre le regroupement
familial
ceci a entraîné le la modification de
cette immigration travail en émigration
d'installation depuis la france a
accueilli des millions d'immigrés sur
son territoire le malheur c'est que
aujourd'hui nous avons sept millions de
chômeurs 9 millions de pauvres nous
n'avons absolument plus les moyens
d'accueillir quiconque
or le système de protection sociale
français fait que lorsque quelqu'un
arrive sur le territoire national
il est pris en charge il est soigné
gratuitement ces enfants sont éduqués
enfin gratuitement il ya bien quelqu'un
qui paye évidemment ce sont les
compatriotes français ils sont logés
dans des logements sociaux et par
conséquent il est moi je crois de bon
sens de dire on ne peut plus mener cette
politique elle nous ruine car nous ne
pouvons pas attirer des personnes
indéfiniment qui n'ont pas d'emploi qui
n'en trouveront pas puisque nous avons
nous sommes victimes d'un chômage de
masse
je ne vois pas encore une fois ce qui
peut y avoir de raciste dans cette
proposition forme d'intolérance il
d'exclusion c'est ce que ça ne rit pas
ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
vous avez l'air de débiter comme ça il
ya une série de mots sans chercher même
à savoir s'ils correspondent à la moine
réalité qu'est ce que ça veut délivrer
les immigrants qui sont chez vous qui ne
trouveraient pas d'emploi qui voit
qu'ils pourraient pas avoir du travail
pendant une importation des raisons
économiques se verrait peut-être rester
à va partir chez we like it is no hay
mais dites moi madame aux états unis si
moi je vais aux états unis
il faut d'abord une carte pour avoir
l'autorisation de travailler à
l'expiration de cette carte ou si je ne
trouve pas d'emploi est ce que vous
croyez que les américains subviennent à
mes besoins
sûrement pas et à l'expiration de ma
carte on me renvoie dans mon pays c'est
la plupart des pays très objectivement
mettre en oeuvre ce qui apparaît comme
une politique rationnelle une politique
sage une politique de bon sens je ne
vois pas pourquoi la france ne pourrait
pas la mettre en oeuvre
joe faire entendre un extrait de notre
ministre de l'immigration du canada cmec
alors je pense qu'il y a au canada un
bon consensus au moins parmi la classe
politique au québec et au canada en
faveur de ces réfugiés
donc le fait que selon ce que j'ai
entendu les politiciens ne veulent pas
lui parler ne me surprend pas alors
c'est notre ministre de l'immigration
oui à qui il est là pour organiser
l'immigration oui bill est ce que ça
fait c'est pas tout à fait
extraordinaire qu'on soit en désaccord
non par ces séquences sur la sphère des
migrants j'ai eu de la manière la plus
claire qui soit l'état islamique se sert
des flux de migrants pour infiltrer un
certain nombre de terroristes
c'est un fait ça a fait des dizaines de
morts en france puisque trois des
terroristes du bataclan 3 était
précisément des gens qui s'étaient
infiltrés dans les flux de migrants à la
demande de l'état islamique il y en a
sûrement d'autres d'ailleurs qu'ils le
font j'ai donc dit que je considérais
qu'accepter ces flux de migrants était
un grand danger car vous êtes qu'elle
ait 25 mai le canada est une folie ici
les immigrants qui ont été reçus cyr ont
été sélectionnés dans les camps de
réfugiés
il était là depuis souvent durant trois
ans quatre ans 25 ans et que c'est
peut-être la part d'humanité des
canadiens et des québécois de vouloir
les seconds mais madame sait très bien
que si les conditions de sécurité sont
absolument
régler aucun problème sur les affaires
terroristes vous me dites il n'y aura
aucune difficulté
j'espère je n'ai pas si vous dites ça a
été très bien fait il une sécurité
totale on sait parfaitement qu'ils sont
soit je le souhaite figurez vous je le
souhaite pour la sécurité des québécois
maintenant ouvrir des flux d'immigration
lorsque l'on sait comme madame merkel
d'ailleurs l'a appris à ses dépens que
lorsque vous accueillez une personne et
bien il y en a dix qui prennent la route
pour venir le rejoindre
je crois qu'on crée là des phénomènes de
flux migratoires qu'on ne pourra pas
gérer et la preuve en est c'est que
l'union européenne est incapable de les
gérer
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des pays ferme
les frontières les uns après les autres
même les plus généreux même ceux qui se
disaient très ouvert à l'accueil sont en
train d'envisager de renvoyer les
migrants chez eux et ferment encore une
fois les uns après les autres leurs
frontières
jeudi il ne faut pas être naïf en ce
domaine voilà on organise des flux
d'immigration que bien probablement on
n'arrivera pas à gérer dans le futur ça
me paraît être une politique néfaste je
pense qu'il aurait dû faire mais on
aurait dû faire l' inverse notamment
mettre en place la politique mise en
oeuvre par l'australie qui a évité
d'ailleurs qu'il y ait des successions
de mort dans la méditerranée par noyade
puisque ces pauvres tentent de venir
évidemment sur les rives de l'union
européenne et une grande partie d'entre
eux se noie je pense que c'est la
conséquence d'une politique dévastatrice
d'immigration menée par l'union
européenne que je combats se peut-il que
la politique canada ne soit pas une
folie s'il ya en europe cette pose un
problème qu'au canada ce ne soit pour
nous en parlerons dans dix ans peut-être
ou peut-être même avant mais si vous
êtes présidente de la france
est ce que tout ce que vous proposez
serait réalisée dur au lendemain c'est à
dire contre l'euro vous inquiétez
l'espace schengen aux frontières
évidemment de l'immigration
est-ce que je suis attaché à la
souveraineté je pense qu'un peuple net
heureux que quand il lit libre
aujourd'hui la france n'est pas libre
par conséquent si je suis élu président
de la république j'irai me tourner vers
l'union européenne en lui demandant de
nous rendre notre souveraineté et au
moins quatre piliers de notre
souveraineté est essentielle
notre souveraineté territoriale je veux
savoir qui entre et qui se maintient sur
mon territoire
parce que je crois que c'est le droit du
peuple français qu'une la souveraineté
monétaire dont d'ailleurs fait partie
les problématiques de l'euro la
souveraineté économique dont fait partie
notre souveraineté bancaire et notre
souveraineté législatives je veux que
les lois votées à la demande du peuple
français est à une autorité supérieure
aux directives européennes
voilà ce que j'ai à négocier exactement
comme en grande bretagne soit l'union
européenne me dit d'accord alors nous
restons dans l'union peine soit l'union
européenne me dit il n'en est pas
question
et à ce moment là je proposerai aux
français de sortir de l'union européenne
par référendum
voilà ce que je compte faire en premier
parce que si nous ne retrouvons pas
notre souveraineté alors nous ne
pourrons mener aucune des politiques qui
sont nécessaires madame le pen vous avez
entrepris j'ai employé un mot qui était
juste et surtout en france par les les
journalistes les commentateurs les
observateurs quand on parle du front
national et conduit la dédiabolisation
humaines et de comment des documentaires
là dessus pour faire du front national
un parti comme un autre et votre slogan
je crois c'est la france à plaisir
si je me trompe pas quand je parle de
seulement la france apaisée et on peut
se poser la question que je vous la pose
est ce que on apaise la france quand on
met l'accent sur des peurs qu'on peut
créer chez les gens face à l'immigration
face au terrorisme face à la situation
économique
soyez très sincèrement la question est
très sincèrement que c'est moi qui crée
la peur du terrorisme madame nouvelles
sont les autres absents ce sont les 130
morts du bataclan où ce sont les six
attentats qui ont eu lieu en france dans
les dernières
vous croyez sincèrement que c'est moi
qui suscite la peur non madame moi je
parle des vrais problèmes
moi je refuse de cacher les yeux moi je
refuse d'être dans le déni
moi j'appelle un chat un chat et parce
que j'analyse les problèmes parce que
j'ai le courage de les regarder en face
j'ai les solutions à leur appliquer
lorsque je vois que des responsables
politiques quels que soient les pays
d'ailleurs et des responsables
politiques du mien en particulier sont
incapables de dire que les auteurs des
attentats sont des fondamentalistes
islamistes
il n'ose même pas dire le terme est ce
que vous croyez que quand on n'est pas
capable de mettre un mot et noter que
sur un mal est ce que vous croyez
sincèrement qu'on est capable de le
régler je ne le crois pas voilà je crois
que pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre une
solution
encore faut-il être capable de faire le
bon diagnostic qui ne sont pas capables
de faire le bon diagnostic et que tant
qu'on n'aura pas fait cela alors il n'y
aura pas d'apaisement pour mon pays
alors mon pays vivra dans la peur du
terrorisme et je ne le souhaite pas donc
oui je veux une france apaisée et pour
qu'elles soient apaisées puis il faut
régler les problèmes économiques il faut
rendre la liberté au peuple français il
faut rétablir la démocratie il faut
lutter contre l'immigration massive
il faut lutter contre le communautarisme
il faut lutter contre le terrorisme
islamiste et qui paiera le canada lutte
également contre le terrorisme islamiste
ya pas de négation du terrorisme
islamiste
il reste une chance de faire entendre
une publicité qui est sorti en france ce
week-end qui ont pu lui faire faire par
le gouvernement si on la fait rentable
attention ces propos et ses images
peuvent choquer et comme d'hab
qui c'est qui fout le bordel
les arabes toute façon c'est comme ça
sont tous agressif c'est dans leur
nature
ils font aucun effort pense et puis de
toute façon ils sont comme nous si vous
êtes sérieux
vous y croyez à ce que vous dit rien le
racisme c'est commence par des mots ça
finit par des crachats des coûts du son
réagissons tous unis contre l'aisne
j'ai vu que le gouvernement français
avait effectué deux clips 1 contre le
racisme est un contre l'antisémitisme
je note qu'il n'y en a pas contre le
racisme anti blanc et le racisme anti
français
or c'est hélas un type de délits qui se
multiplient aujourd'hui en france et
qu'il a en encore semble avoir moins
d'importance aux yeux du gouvernement
alors moi je lutte contre tous les
racismes tous les racismes sans
exception madame le pen
on a beaucoup évoqué aussi ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis en tout cas au
canada on en parle beaucoup de ce qui se
passe de monsieur tron est ce que vous
avez qu'est ce qui représente pour vous
donne un train il est comme monsieur
sanders
ils sont deux figures qui émerge de la
vie politique américaine parce que je
pense que les américains en ont passé
d'une classe politique qui semble
défendre systématiquement des intérêts
privés plutôt que de défendre l'intérêt
général et que le peuple américain
souhaite des gens libres des
responsables politiques libres libres de
des entraves libre des lobbys
des renvois d'ascenseur et que ce soit
monsieur 100 places pour les démocrates
ce train pour les républicains
eh bien ils sont ils représentent cette
aspiration à des hommes politiques
libres de toutes ces chaînes
mais quand monsieur 30 propose de
dresser des murs d'exclure les les
migrants est ce que vous sentez que vous
avez des affinités davantage avec lui
qu'avec monsieur sanders
mais je ne me pose même pas cette
question je ne me pose pas cette
question parce que je crois que c'est
aux américains encore une fois de se
choisir leur siège comme les québécois
d'ailleurs mais je trempe dit des choses
qui sont juste pour partie il ya un
certain nombre d'autres de ses propos
auquel je n'adhère pas
je n'insulte pas pour autant je ne le
traite pas de tous les noms pour autant
parce qu'encore une fois moi je suis
respectueuse de la démocratie je pense
que l'insultent c'est le contraire de la
démocratie
donc on dit qu'on est en désaccord avec
quelqu'un mais on ne le traite pas le
raciste de xénophobe de fasciste et
cédera pas ce que ça c'est la facilité
ça c'est quand on a pas d'arguments non
mais ça quand on est incapable d'avoir
un argument sur le fond on utilise c'est
ce que la nuit on sort la boîte à
insultes et on se sert racistes
xénophobes et settat et on pense qu'on
va comme ça discréditer l'adversaire
sans avoir besoin d'échanger des idées
de confronter des arguments c'est
précisément d'ailleurs en gros ce que
vous faites depuis le début de cette
émission
et qu'est ce que vous n'aimez pas dans
les scandales monsieur tron de quoi vous
souciez vous mais je me dis ceci par
exemple de la manière dont il
différencie les gens en fonction de la
religion
moi je ne le fais pas mais voilà il le
fait les électeurs jugent mais je ne
suis pas sur la même ligne que lui en ce
domaine
voilà voilà un exemple et vous savez en
france on regarde - la politique
américaine que vous ne le faites
ben ouais ça nous va bien c'est le
voisin quand même c'est monsieur trump
il
il soulève énorme et est un phénomène
c'est un phénomène monsieur tram women
politiques un phénomène politique parce
que je crois qu'il est en rond avec la
classe politique traditionnelle
précisément malade le pen merci merci à
vous